hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen video
hervor ich mit dem anfangen was ich
schon im titel eingeblendet sieht
nämlich musicali noch eine ganz kurze
sache ich habe heute ein bisschen zeit
deswegen schaffe ich theoretisch heute
noch ein zweites video hochzuladen
bezüglich einer sache die auch was mit
waffen zu tun hat wenn ihr also heute
noch ein zweites video haben folgen
lassen leiter und bei 30.000 lies kommt
heute noch ein zweites video also ihr
entscheidet quasi darüber musicali ihr
seht es im titel eingeblendet jeder
hasst musicali ich stelle mich heute
dieser frage warum das vielleicht jeder
tut und warum auch jeder solche videos
dazu hoch lädt anna latif nicht genau
wissen musicali ist eine musikplattform
bei der man sich ein profil anlegen kann
hat man dort profil es ist logisch wenn
man sich im profil angelegt hat was
kannst du und ich hoffe dieser plattform
ist es dann möglich dass man sich ein
lied auswählen wie aus den charts und
das kann man dann abspielen lassen und
dazu bewegt man sein und dann kommt
dabei witzige videos raus wo es so aus
als würde man selber das lied gesungen
haben oder dazu getanzt haben oder
deswegen was witziges gemacht haben ist
ja an sich eine coole sache oder coole
idee ich meine ich selber hast die
plattform nicht aber ich versuche euch
gerade zu erklären oder den leuten zu
zeigen wie verpassen warum sie sich
vielleicht passen und wie sie damit
aufhören können eine plattform zu helfen
obwohl ich fange mal an ich würde mich
diesem video thema weil ich jetzt auch
schon drei musical videos glaube ich
hochgeladen habe und unter jedem halt
99% wirklich positives feedback in den
kommentaren war dass sich leute
unterhalten konnte und so weiter und so
fort allerdings kommen halte an und
sagen euro luca du springst du auch live
music ally trennen wird auch was soll
das ich habe die plattform ist es
bescheuert wie talk about sanfte die
plattform musicals nicht daran schuld
dass ihr musical i hast
die leute sind daran schuld hier hast
nicht die plattform sondern ihr hasst
die leute auf der plattform und das
sehen sehr viele falsche erstmal zu dem
thema warum lade ich mir sicher die
videos hoch grund eins ich nachholen was
ich will ist ein standard und youtube
broadcast yourself ich kann auch ein
video hochladen mich auf dem klo setzte
zweite sache musik nicht einfach ein
derzeitiges youtube thema so wie das
früher beispielsweise der
style waren jeder eine parodie zugang
hochgeladen oder halt seine eigene
version davon vor kurzem gab
beispielsweise auf dem burghof wo jeder
irgendwas poco hochgeladen hat
irgendwelche unterhaltungstalent welche
songs und parodien dazu gemacht gaming
kann jeder haushalt abgezockt von
derzeit ist es halt einfach so das
musical lieder und half genießt also
steht derzeit der im fokus ihrer macht
videos dazu dass ich mir das ganze noch
höher geschaukelt deswegen mache ich
einfach auf videos dazu weil zeit
einfach ein derzeitiges youtube thema
ist dritte sache ich nutze die plattform
selbst ich habe selber musical aida und
ich heiße dort laser luca jemanden
beispiel eines musicals und ich meine
über alles was ich selber nutze mache
ich natürlich videos weil dieses video
machen jeden tag daily auf youtube ist
natürlich auch ein bisschen mein leben
und ich nutze auch instagram mache
deswegen beispielsweise offen bei
instagram bildern nachstellen ich nutze
snapshot und haben für beispielsweise
oft das so gemacht das geben wir fragen
videos per slapshot senden konnte es
nutze twitter und deswegen können ihre
bei twitter unter dem hashtag luca
reagiert videos einen sender auf die ich
sehr oft reagiert habe also ich nutze
einfach sehr vieles und das was ich
nutze zeige ich auch in meinen videos
deswegen finde ich überhaupt nicht
verwerflich dass ich auch über musicali
content produzieren die vierte und
letzte sache es macht mir spaß und der
sinn hinter youtube sollte sein dass es
einem spaß macht und dass man spaß an
dem content hat den mann hochlädt und
dass man sich damit identifizieren kann
es sind gerade 32 grad raus und hab ich
jetzt keine lust mich vor dem pc zu
setzen und irgendwelche spiele
aufzunehmen da habe ich dann vielleicht
einfach mehr notwenig sein im winter in
meinem zimmer sitze mit einem tee und
dann einfach zocke und das halt
hochladen kann aber gerade machen
einfach mehr bock mich vor die kamera zu
stellen und darüber zu lagern
ich lade jeden tag das hoch worauf ich
bemerkt dass wahrscheinlich schon ich
bin kein kanal der in serie hat die
immer wieder kommen ich meine piloten
ist ein perfektes beispiel dafür hat
serien jahr über 200
und das bin ich super cool und ich habe
respekt vor leuten die sich so lange
sowas aufhalten können ich bin nicht so
jemandem ich muss youtube jeden tag eine
neue herausforderung so etwas
hochzuladen was ich irgendwie noch nicht
in der form gemacht habe ich weiß nicht
ob mir das jetzt verstehen konnten aber
das sind diese vier hauptgründe warum
ich videos zum musical die hochladen und
jetzt gehe ich noch mal ganz kurz darauf
ein wie ich es mir erklären dass herr
viele leute die plattform musical
einfach verabscheue darf ich jetzt keine
gründe vorbereitet allerdings es ist ja
so dass wirklich der hauptprodukt von 99
der hater die gegen musicali sind er
besitzt nur so eine plattform
pubertierende kinder ihre schönheit
zeigen
aber was kann denn die plattform dafür
meiner meinung nach sind leute die sagen
dass sie die plattform music bzw
im video zu musical total scheiße finden
weil er nur diese kinder ihre schnauze
rennstrecken und sich mit den händen
durch die haare gehen und irgendwelche
sehen jährigen mädels um den daumen
wickeln oder so leute die so über die
plattform reden sind wirklich
unreflektierte menschen weil es geht
nicht um die plattform sondern dann geht
es um die leute die das machen das wäre
genauso wie wenn ein künstler auf der
plattform you seek nie sagen würde über
youtube wo ich hasse youtube weil der
laden ja alle diesen
sexuellen content da hoch weil er
einfach nur katja service dingsbums
kennt ich weiß nicht ob ich versteht was
ich meine aber das ist einfach so es
gibt so viel mehr auf der plattform
musicali als leute die irgendwie so
machen bei einem drop und irgendwie was
komisches es gibt so viele kreative gute
richtigen als musical ließ aber die
leute beziehen sicherheit wirklich nur
auf das negative an der plattform und es
ist einfach leute die nicht reflektiert
sind die sich nicht das ganze betrachten
sondern einfach nicht nur das negative
rauspicken und sagen okay das packt mich
ab lass mich in ruhe mit der plattform
hoffe ich konnte mit meinen stand vom
irgendwie näher bringen also ich finds
halt immer traurig zu lesen ich hasse
musical die macht dazu noch keine videos
aber die plattform an sich ist cool ich
meine es ist eine idee dass leute ihren
mund dazu bewegen können wie sie ein
lied hören und es gibt einfach viele
leute die plattform falsch nutzen und
ich kann es irgendwie teil es verstehen
dass solche leute auch nicht gemacht
werden weil sie einfach den sinn der
plattform nicht richtig sehen es sollte
nicht die komplette plattform dafür
geerntet werden und es ist nicht bezahlt
von musical bekommen kein geld dafür
dass ihr so oft sage oder so wird es
fakt mich einfach ab ich glaube dieses
video hat überhaupt keinen roten faden
ich habe euch einfach nur als heute mal
gesagt warum ich mir die videos
hochladen und ließ mir erkläre dass sehr
viele leute das nicht leisten dass so
viele youtuber der über videos machen
ich hoffe dass es irgendwie angekommen
wer durch das video gefallen hat würde
ich mich freuen die gesagt für 30.000
like sein ich heute abend nochmal video
auf seiner sache die ich derzeit haste
was gestern vorgestellt wurde und mit
apple zu tun hat hier oben könnt ihm
einen kanal abonnieren und hier unten
findet ihr ein video von mir zu musical
ihn nämlich wo ich zehn arten von
musical die nutzer vorgestellt habe also
abonniert mich und guckt dieses video an
das ist sehr cool
wolf instagram slap ship musik in die
laser luca ein feature das nächste wm